[Music]  here's the thing  we're a team of thieves  then when you do this  you're bound to make enemies  sometimes those enemies come looking for  revenge  truth be told  we helped the wrong person steal the  wrong thing  we didn't mean to unleash the greatest  evil the world has ever known  but we're gonna fix it  so how do we pull that off  uh  figure it out over a drink probably best  you need food give us a fighting chance  we're gonna need strength you got this  right i know you don't  we also need courage  magic  and you  what is that again it's an owl there  be warned  there is evil here  i'm glad he's on our side  this one's dangerous  but whatever happens  we'll be ready  is it exactly that you bring to this i'm  a planner i make plans you've already  made plans so if the existing plan fails  i make a new plan so you make plans that  fail no he also plays the loot not  relevant  [Music]  you